in this
down period between christmas and new
year's
this is a time when in the past i would
probably
be seeing quite a few of my my family
and when i say my family
i generally mean my adoptive mother's
family and i'm going to tell some
stories about
one of those family members who's
actually been gone
a very long time but who made a massive
imprint upon not just my life but the
life
of so many other people within the
family and that
is my uncle actually great uncle
hubert everybody called him you know
monok or monokubai
because you know where my mother's
family is french-canadian
and so hubert lemry's he was born
in the early teens of the last
century and he died if i remember right
in 1990 or 1991
of of cancer and complications from that
and he lived a pretty long and
a really good life in in many respects
he saw
quite a few hard times he actually
at one time had a grocery store which uh
went under during the depression
and wound up having to
work a good part of his life as a
welder although that wasn't his
preferred job he was he was extremely
good at it and so
you know let me start sort of at the
start not necessarily of his life
because i don't actually
know that much about it and almost
everybody who could tell us anything
about that has long since passed on but
i'll tell you about
what it was like knowing him so
he was always there you know as far back
as i can
remember and i should probably give a
little bit of background
so my my mother's side of the family
she grew up in chicago on a block
that was pretty much all either french
canadians or menominee indians just
about everybody spoke
french and she was a fourth generation
immigrant you could say because our
great great grandfather
came over to fight in the civil war
ended up settling in
in new england and eventually in the 19
i think late 20s early 30s the family
settled in chicago
and so my my great uncle yubert would
have been
the grandson of of that ancestor
and it was his dad and mom who
everyone called mamey and pape you know
they were the grandparents to everybody
they settled in chicago brought all the
kids with them and there was a lot of
adventures we could talk about i mean
pape actually put together a band and
got a jalopy together
and had the kids like a bunch of
neighborhood kids you know
driving all the way to the rockies
playing
there's all sorts of stories and uncle
hubert was part of those stories as a
kid
uh he played the trombone believe it or
not our family's very musical
and so uncle eubert
was one of the oldest of of the the kids
i think he may have been the second
oldest
and eileen would have been the oldest
and she married
raul uh who was from canada and this is
what the family did
they would they would have um spouses
from canada and bring them down to
that part of chicago where they lived
and so
you know my mom her mom was from quebec
as was her sister who married my uncle
hubert two brothers married two
sisters and um
so you know you know in a way she was my
mom was a fourth generation immigrant in
a certain way she was also
you know like a second generation
immigrant and
uncle eubert as one of the oldest boys
in the family who wasn't going to be a
priest which
which is what happened with two of the
boys in the very big family
he you know went to grade school i think
he
got through fourth grade at most and
then he had to drop out to start
working uh to support the family because
everybody had to do something the girls
went you know all the way to high
school um the boys most of them in that
older generation
ended up dropping out and so you know he
started working
and eventually he he actually had a
grocery store that he
unfortunately had to run into the ground
you know because of people not being
able to to pay
at different times and uncle eubert
one of the most important things to know
about him was
although he had a very short education
he really valued literacy and really
valued
reading and so he read his entire life
and he was probably one of the best red
people that i've known he's a great
example of the fact that you don't have
to go to school
necessarily to to be intelligent and
literate
and to to you know learn what what
what's available to learn you can in
fact do it on your own
and and he did and he was always curious
about things
so it wasn't just reading say novels or
stuff like that he read the popular
science stuff of his time
he was interested in astronomy he was
interested in in history
he started buying national geographics
when he was quite young
and collected them all the way up until
his death
and when he died they were there in his
library going all the way up to
you know 1991 i think and
because of his interest in reading and
because he he valued it so much
that when the rest of the family was say
playing cards or doing stuff like that
he would go and retire to read um
he wound up being sort of like 11
that you know fertilized so many other
people's
imaginations and i'll give you some
examples of how that took place
so as a kid for myself
he would always get me books at
christmas and i loved that because i
i started reading when i was about three
and i enjoyed the sort of stuff that
he'd get me like you know they have
these alfred hitchcock
presents horror stories he would also
for my birthday get me magazine
subscriptions
and they weren't like bs magazines you
know
uh they weren't the sort of things that
would just appeal to
uh easy reading he was like you're
getting you're getting science magazine
for
for for your birthday you know enjoy it
and and i would read this stuff and i'd
be like this is amazing that's like
where i learned about
games theory from for example and
the the thing that was really cool about
uncle eubert
is he wouldn't just let you drop borrow
books he had a great library and he
would let me
borrow books and and he'd never asked
for him back i took so many books out of
his library
and he'd give you books he would come
later on and he'd say
so what did you think of that book what
did you get out of that book what did
you
learn what did you like what did you not
like
and he actually kept notebooks that i
found later on
long after his death where every single
book that he read
he had entries in there and he would say
what he liked about the book what he
thought was good he'd give it a rating
he also did this with movies as well and
i still have some of them
in storage now he did this not just with
me
but with everybody else in the family
and when we talk about the family
we're talking about this entire lemery's
clan
going back to mamey and pape so there
were 13 brothers and sisters
who survived one of them died in the the
spanish influenza
a couple of them didn't have kids two of
them became priests
so that left about maybe seven branches
each of whom
had anywhere from three to eight kids
and all of those cousins that's my mom's
generation they lived on the same block
in the summer they went out to a farm in
indiana that all these brothers bought
where
eventually they they would retire
and so they spent a lot of time together
and
and uncle hubert and antony were one of
the childless couples
so they were sort of like everybody's
extra parents
and and uncle eubert was the literacy
guy
he was the one who took my mom to
not just to the library all the time
which he did with all the other kids but
he took her to
depaul to sign up for classes
to register to go to to go to college
you know and my mom she kind of took the
easy way she decided she was going to be
a french teacher since you know she
already spoke french as her first
language
and so she you know she was going to
blaze through her classes
but if it hadn't been for uncle eubert's
influence
no nobody else in the family was saying
to their kids you should go to college
if it hadn't been for that i certainly
wouldn't have been adopted into the
family that i was because
it was in college going to a party
actually
uh that my mom met my dad who was up at
the
university of wisconsin-madison at the
time
she met him through i think one of his
friends knew one of her friends
or something like that and um
so uncle eubert was he was somebody who
really
exemplified he didn't just push but he
exemplified what it was to be
a curious intellectually active
literate person who didn't have
pretensions
who realized that reading was something
you got to do
not as a profession but in your spare
time
you had to make time for it and that it
was valuable
even if nobody else was going to value
it
it was it was worth doing and it was
worth doing
well and so you know he was an
incredible influence in that way
but there were other aspects of hubert
as well
that i thought were really great too
another thing that that he and i share
in common
is a love of nature
and horticulture and and gardening
and uh particularly of flowers and he
was he was a pretty
amazing gardener i remember
so i should tell you a few other things
when he retired and he retired from
being a welder and apparently he was
an amazing welder he didn't really like
the job but he had to do it to make
money
after his his store failed um but he
could do things and
my family is a family of crafts people
so when they say that
he was doing things that were beyond
them they mean it
it's not just you know uh hipsters
playing around with with torches or
something these are people who really
knew their stuff
so he was he was really diligent in his
work
so anyway he retired my grandfather
also retired and my uncle ernie great
uncle ernie another one of the brothers
retired
and there were actually five brothers
who were supposed to retire
and move out to this land that they had
bought in in northwestern indiana
near rose lawn and three of them ended
up doing that they all bought wausau
homes
they actually all bought the exact same
model of home
just with slightly different wallpaper
and you know like the the appliances
were different colors
that's that's the the amount that they
they uh personalize the houses
and grandpa and uncle hubert's house
were built
basically side by side with a four-car
garage in between them and then a deck
on top of that garage
and at that time you know in their 60s
these were really
vital uh people my you know grandpa and
grandma
aunts and uncles um and and they you
know
they they made this land that which was
essentially just sand
into a really wonderful place especially
for me because i spent
many of my summers out there and that's
where we also had you know easter and
christmas
and all the family gatherings for our
side of the the la marie's family
uncle eubert built shelves
running through the whole basement and
it was just stocked with books as a
matter of fact
when when places were closing
like seminaries they would just give him
all of their books because he knew they
knew that it wouldn't go to waste he
would give them to other people
or he would put them on his shelves
and so every time that i was there i
could go downstairs and find
you know really cool novels or science
books or science fiction stuff or
you know the national geographics that i
was i was talking about
and he'd let you read anything you
wanted even if it was a little bit too
adult for you
he'd be like that's fine you know
there's a little bit of sex in that but
you know it's not like you're you're not
going to get introduced to that sooner
or later he he was a
he was not a prudish guy but he was also
you know a really
uh good sort of moral voice going back
to the gardening thing though so
they they bought this land and uncle
eubert
now grandpa and uncle ernie they
cultivated the garden garden right
everybody worked on that including
including me when i was there in the
summer
you all have chores but then uncle
hubert did all sorts of other things he
planted
rows and rows of roses if you've ever
done roses
they're a lot of work man i i wouldn't
want to do roses myself
and he planted lilies and irises and all
sorts of other flowers daffodils
everywhere
i mean the entire like spring season
into mid-summer where there were flowers
all over the place hydrangeas he planted
lilacs that he took from the old farm
and brought there he had currents that i
i found you know
the birds had eaten them and you know
the pooped out the seeds in the woods
and i was able to recover
some of the currents that he'd had
originally and
unfortunately when uncle hubert died
in the early 90s my grandfather was so
overcome with grief that he actually
plowed under
all of those roses and currants and
gooseberries and
blackberries uncle hubert had like he
had raspberries they were red and black
and golden
again i cultivated those finding the
golden ones out in in the local woods
and there was just so many beautiful
things that
that eubert did
in in the the land and then i eventually
you know when my mother died i used that
that money from the inheritance to buy
his old house and i i was able to bring
some of those things back
into into being you know to cultivate
them again
and so that was a way of connecting with
with him and you know i went through his
library and kept
a good bit of his his books he was the
one who actually introduced me to a lot
of great horror and fantasy and science
fiction
and um so i i owe him a great debt and
he was a really
gentle man he was a really kind
guy very understanding you could you
could really talk with him just
with just about anything
now i i'm gonna finish by telling kind
of a funny story
so uncle hubert you know he was clearly
like the head of the family when he was
alive
and we had this very long table in the
basement that i was talking about where
the the books were and all that
and that's where we would have all of
our like family meals
particularly at christmas easter you
know
birthdays things like that and he sat at
the head of this
massive table which was probably about
20 feet long
and we'd have chairs all around it you
know um that's also where we'd play
cards and
and you know do things like that um at
one time it had been
a uh it came from some factory
in in chicago so
we would we would chitter chatter back
and forth during meals and we had quite
a few people who were kind of like to
stir the pot
in in my family including my mom you
know
i'll maybe tell some stories about her
down the line as well
and they were arguing about something
and i don't remember what it was um
and and they turned to uncle uber to ask
about something and it had to do with
like the old neighborhood
and so this this super gentle guy
who you know you you wouldn't expect him
to ever
have engaged in any acts of violence
they asked him well what was it like
when you first
went to chicago oh it was really hard
terrible
the and you have to understand that
chicago at that time
was a city of neighborhoods generally
tied to ethnicity
and if you weren't of the right
ethnicity you would suffer
like my mom when she went to elementary
school the irish girls
beat her up you know just for not being
irish and so he said when we first moved
there we had a lot of trouble the irish
would come into our neighborhood and
beat us up and break windows and
you know do all sorts of things to us
and then we figured
out that we we got some hoses and we
filled them up with lead shot
and every time that the irish would come
into our neighborhood
we whip the crap out of them and then
they left us alone and then it was quite
nice you know
and our jaws dropped at the table
because we're picturing uncle hubert who
at that time was like in his
70s you know we're picturing him at
his brothers basically you know creating
blackjacks
and knocking the crap out of people in
ways that probably injured some of them
for life
and that was just the way it was back
then you know and then he just like went
right back to eating his soup and
nobody really said anything about it so
there are many sides to
to these these these people in the
lemery's
family but uncle hubert you know was he
was always
very encouraging um not just of literacy
but about how are you doing in your life
he was very happy that i went to college
um it was it was it was fortunate i mean
it was towards the end of his life and
he was he was suffering quite a bit he
had prostate cancer
and it spread through the rest of his
his body but
i was able to you know see him at least
before
um before the end when i when i had got
i was out of the army and gotten into
college
and we were able to talk and that that
was quite nice and then you know when he
died we
we came down and had his funeral
and there were many people who had great
testimonies about about the guy and we
talked about him we have a family
reunion
every year and at that time the family
reunion
i think it had moved location and so you
know we we talked about him at the
family reunion
as well because he had been heavily
involved with that so
he's somebody that i've been thinking
about over the last couple days
you know um as i've had time to
unwind and read and think about
how i would have talked with him about
some of the people that i'm
reading now and what he would have made
of them
and i'm he's somebody who i'm very
grateful for
i i you know i think i can say that i
wouldn't be
who i am in any real way
had he not exercised the the influence
that he did
on the entire lamrie's family and in
particular
on my on my mom and my dad loved him too
you know
because he was a very lovable guy and
i don't know that i would be where i am
today if it wasn't for his
encouragement and example as as a person
when it comes to reading and also when
it comes to
gardening and plants and flowers in
particular
so that's my story about
monokubai
you